-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Senator Elizabeth Warren.
You are a former Harvard law
professor.
How would you grade the legal
argument that was presented
for overturning Roe v. Wade?
-Oh, bad.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But, you know, I want to say
bad not just --
-Real quick before we go on,
were you a tough grader?
-Yeah.
-Yeah? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So just know if she gives it
an F, Clarence Thomas,
it's probably a D
from somebody else.
-But it's still a D.
-Okay, yeah.
-It's still bad.
Here's what really -- one of the
things that really troubles me
about the way
this opinion was written.
You know, when you're out there
to change something
that has been precedent for half
a century, you would expect to
read an opinion that really is
as grounded in law as you could
possibly make it, that talks
about the restrictions,
what you can't do,
and ultimately really
tries to persuade.
This opinion doesn't
do any of that.
This opinion basically cites
a bunch of folks from the 1700s
and says, "Boy, that's the way
we want to go."
Oh, I'm sorry.
To a time when aristocrats ran
the world, when the only people
who had voices were white men,
and when slavery was a way
for people to make money.
That's not the America we're
trying to build going forward.
And the fact that this opinion
was just such an in-your-face
about people who are truly
going to be hurt from it,
people whose lives are going to
be turned upside down,
people who are poor,
who are not going to have
the opportunity to leave and get
to another state,
women of color who already have
the highest maternal
mortality rates,
14-year-olds who have been raped
by their coaches,
mamas who are already working
three jobs to try
to take care of the families
they've got.
This opinion had nothing about
the human impact of what
it means to take away
the decision that a woman
makes about continuing
a pregnancy and to insert
instead the government
just to come in callously
and makes the decision instead
of the person who is pregnant.
It troubles me to think how
six people could say they have
seized power and care so little
about the people
who will pay the price.
-You know, there's been a lot of
talk about the steps you could
take to maybe change
the direction of the court,
things like stacking the court,
things like term limits.
We talked about
abolishing the filibuster.
These are things that
when they're brought up,
oftentimes people categorize
as extremist positions.
I certainly understand
they sound extreme.
Do you think that as people
watch the court
take such extreme steps and make
decisions that roll back
precedent 50 years,
do you think those extreme steps
seem less extreme to people now?
-I think that that what we're
watching is how many more people
see this as an extremist court
and see the kind of conditions
that this tiny group of radicals
are trying to impose on
the rest of the country
and the kind of threat they pose
to all of us with a decision
on guns,
with a decision on abortion,
with a decision on climate.
Now, I think that means
the first thing we have to do is
remind ourselves
the Supreme Court
doesn't get the final word.
The final word rests with we,
the people.
And that's why it's so important
at this moment to be angry
but to be focused in on
that election in November.
Two senators hang on
to the house.
-You're making it very easy
to follow.
-And we've got this.
But it's so important because,
Seth, understand this,
if we don't do that, they've
already told us the direction
they're headed in.
They're not stopping at Roe.
You didn't hear them at the end
of this say,
"Oh, we got Roe, the climate,
and guns. We're done."
No.
Clarence Thomas already said,
"We're coming after
the LGBTQ community.
We are coming after
contraception.
We are coming after what people
do in the privacy
of their own homes and their
intimate and family lives."
They are coming after the things
we hold dear.
And when you connect that up
with what's happened
with the January 6th
insurrection,
it's not an exaggeration to say
our democracy is truly at stake.
If the Republicans can seize
power, they have made it clear
that they stand
behind Donald Trump,
who wanted to be a dictator,
tried really hard to get there
and got really close.
What scares me is next time
around they're going to
figure out how to
succeed at that.
And that's why what we do
in November is so important.
-I want to try to end on
a little bit more optimism.
We've got the 4th of July
coming.
Are you at least going to give
yourself a break and barbecue?
-You know, a little barbecue,
a little hiking.
-Oh, wow.
-But you got to be back
in the fight the next day.
-Yeah.
-Sorry.
That's how everything turns,
right?
-Seems like 24 hours is about
all the time
you'll give anybody to do
anything. Yeah.
-Yeah, that's --
-That's not fighting.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here, Senator.
It's always a pleasure.
-So good to see you.
-Senator Elizabeth Warren,
everybody.
We'll be right back
with Cazzie David.